Traduttore: Veronica Viscardi
Revisore: Ludovica Harley
Ora parliamo di geni,
quelli che stanno dentro le cellule.
Come sapete tutte hanno
un manuale di istruzioni
per fare altre cellule, manuale
di istruzioni che è il DNA.
Ci sono circa 20.000 pagine
in questo manuale.
Ognuna è un gene.
Eppure un piccolo errore,
una lettera sbagliata
in uno di questi fogli,
può causare una malattia genetica grave,
con conseguenze anche devastanti.
Se però è un'istruzione che è sbagliata,
non possiamo intervenire
e aggiungere un foglio supplementare
di informazioni che vadano a correggere.
Questa è l'idea alla base
della terapia genica.
I geni diventano farmaci,
che noi somministriamo a una cellula,
presa da un organismo,
oppure direttamente nell'organismo,
per correggere un difetto genetico.
O talvolta, se vogliamo essere
ancora più ambiziosi,
per istruire una nuova funzione.
Per inserire però i geni
nel DNA delle cellule
dobbiamo essere
particolarmente efficienti.
Non sono facili da trasportare
i geni tra una cellula e l'altra.
Ce ne sono di gelose della loro identità.
Chi lo sa fare bene
in natura sono i virus.
Quindi l'idea della terapia genica
è usare i virus come dei cavalli di Troia.
Rifacendomi a questo mito fondazionale
della nostra cultura mediterranea
in cui c'è la dissimulazione,
c'è l'inganno,
ma c'è anche l'astuzia di Achille
che aveva nascosto
i guerrieri greci nel cavallo
che i Troiani si portano in casa
pensando che sia un dono degli dei.
Come fanno i virus
a entrare nelle cellule?
Soprattutto si portano dietro i loro geni,
le istruzioni per fare altri virus.
Quando il virus da solo
non è capace di vita autonoma,
sfrutta la cellula
per produrre altre particelle.
Quando però lascia la cellula,
si deve portare dietro
le sue informazioni, i suoi geni.
E li va a pescare tra le migliaia di altri
perché questi geni hanno
una sorta di codice, codice postale,
un punto virus com, se volete,
con cui si porta via solo i suoi geni.
E allora in laboratorio possiamo usare
questo punto virus com
e in realtà attaccarlo al gene terapeutico
che vogliamo inserire nella cellula.
E poi il nostro virus diventa
questo cavallo di Troia
che entra nella cellula e vi porta
non i suoi geni ma il gene terapeutico.
Se vogliamo, in questo caso è il virus
che viene ingannato in questo meccanismo
e che porta dentro la cellula
un gene utile
e che istruisce una nuova funzione
o corregge un difetto genetico.
Se quella cellula la passa
alle cellule figlie rimarrà funzionale.
Questo si può fare in modo
ancora più efficace
se noi usiamo delle cellule
un po' particolari
che sono le cellule staminali,
per esempio quelle del sangue,
che si mantengono nell'organismo
e che generano una progenie di cellule
che poi vanno a diffondersi
attraverso il sangue nei vari tessuti.
Isolando le cellule staminali del sangue,
introducendo quindi un gene terapeutico,
noi possiamo generare tutta una progenie,
e possibilmente anche
per la vita di un individuo,
di cellule della serie bianca,
della serie rossa,
delle varie cellule del sangue
che potranno diffondersi nell'organismo
e correggere dei difetti genetici gravi,
come le malattie dell'immunità,
malattie del sangue, come le talassemie,
ma anche malattie da accumulo nei tessuti
dove manca, nella malattia genetica,
il modo per smaltire questi tessuti.
Qual è stata però la principale difficoltà
per molti anni nel campo,
a fronte di questa idea,
in fondo semplice, di introdurre i geni
e di avere un cavallo di Troia
efficiente a sufficienza
per entrare nelle cellule umane
in modo adeguato?
E qui l'idea è stata di pensare davvero
a prendere il coraggio con le mani
e a usare un virus così temibile
come era HIV, il virus dell'AIDS,
che però, ahimè, è anche un virus
estremamente efficiente
per entrare nelle cellule umane.
Addomesticare questo virus
in modo efficace
e rendendolo da una parte sicuro,
ma dall'altra mantenendone l'abilità
di entrare nelle cellule e diventare
un veicolo amichevole per noi.
Lavorare con un virus che è stato,
ed è tuttora una delle pesti principali
che abbia colpito l'umanità,
lasciando un numero drammatico di morti
e che continua a essere un virus verso cui
non dobbiamo abbassare la guardia,
non vuol dire però che non si possa
in realtà, utilizzando la tecnologia,
renderlo sufficientemente sicuro
come veicolo.
In questo caso un virus
così neutralizzato,
che diventa capace di portare un messaggio
terapeutico benefico nelle cellule.
Un lavoro che abbiamo fatto,
come avete visto, per più di 15 anni,
prima di arrivare
alla sperimentazione sull'uomo
con il supporto cruciale di una fondazione
come quella di Telethon
che ci ha aiutato e negli anni
ha creduto in quest'idea
e che ha portato oggi a potere
dire che per una volta, finalmente,
una sorta di rivincita ce la siamo presa
contro questo virus così temibile,
perché abbiamo potuto,
con le belle parole che ha detto
il Corriere in questo articolo,
riportare il sorriso su tanti bambini
che altrimenti oggi non avrebbero avuto
la possibilità di vivere una vita
senza questo intervento terapeutico.
Bambini che, come vedete, vengono
un po' da tutto il Mediterraneo e da fuori
che possono avere,
con questi nuovi approcci,
una speranza di trattamento.
In realtà con la terapia genica si può
andare anche oltre la malattia genetica.
Si può per esempio istruire le cellule
a fare qualcosa che non sapevano fare,
per esempio attaccare un tumore.
Le cellule dell'immunità, come sapete,
sono delle cellule capaci di uccidere
una cellula in un tessuto.
E per uccidere questa cellula usano
un recettore sulla loro membrana
che fa riconoscere queste cellule tumorali
piuttosto che altre.
Però spesso non lo sanno fare.
Noi possiamo in laboratorio costruire
dei recettori molto efficienti,
che possono andare verso il tumore
e possiamo,
con il virus di cui vi dicevo prima,
inserire questi nuovi recettori
nella cellula dell'immunità,
rendendola quindi più intelligente.
Uno dei problemi che troviamo, però, è che
questa cellula aveva già un suo recettore
e quindi in realtà ci troviamo
in una cellula confusa,
che a questo punto segue
due segnali diversi,
e non sappiamo esattamente
come si comporterà.
Di nuovo l'intervento della terapia genica
può servirci, in che modo.
Provando a fare i chirurghi del DNA,
andando a eliminare il gene
che dentro quella cellula
istruiva il suo recettore,
quello originale, che non ci serve più,
tagliare il DNA in quel punto specifico.
Possiamo farlo perché abbiamo
imparato in laboratorio
a decifrare il codice di quelle proteine
che legano il DNA,
non ovunque, ma sulla base
della sua sequenza specifica.
Abbiamo potuto decifrare questo codice
e possiamo quindi costruire in laboratorio
delle molecole artificiali,
che vanno a legarsi,
a riconoscere il DNA dove c'è
una specifica sequenza.
Quindi in un punto che noi abbiamo scelto,
per esempio in quel gene
che vogliamo tagliare.
A questo punto possiamo inattivare
quel gene, la nostra cellula rimane nuda,
e con il virus che abbiamo addomesticato,
inserire soltanto il nuovo recettore
che la porterà verso il tumore,
in modo più efficace e formidabile
rispetto agli approcci precedenti.
C'è infine un traguardo ancora
più ambizioso che possiamo porci,
poiché quando noi tagliamo il DNA
in un punto specifico,
la cellula prima di riaggiustare
questo taglio,
e quindi introdurre magari degli errori,
come vi ho fatto vedere prima,
e quindi distruggendo quel gene
che abbiamo tagliato,
cerca in realtà di ricopiare
la sequenza originale
per ripristinare la situazione
di partenza.
È un modo più sicuro di riparare.
Allora anche qui possiamo essere
più furbi della cellula
e inserire uno stampo da copiare,
che porti una sequenza simile
a quella che abbiamo tagliato,
ma con la modifica
che volevamo introdurre.
In questo modo la cellula ricopia
la nuova sequenza al posto originale.
Abbiamo fatto quello
che noi chiamiamo l'editing.
In qualche modo immaginate un tipografo
che lavora su un foglio delle istruzioni
e riscrive quelle stesse istruzioni
magari correggendo una mutazione genetica
o inserendo una nuova funzione,
in modo così mirato e preciso.
Siamo quindi davanti a un nuovo campo
che si apre alla medicina molecolare,
dove per la prima volta i farmaci
diventano qualcosa di molto più complesso.
I farmaci fino a oggi sono stati
piccole molecole
che basano la loro funzione sul fatto
di legarsi a una superficie molecolare.
Oppure sono in certi casi delle molecole
più complesse.
Qui i farmaci sono geni, quindi sono
informazioni per fare delle proteine.
Informazioni che tra l'altro
si possono controllare,
possono fare sì che
una volta somministrate,
queste informazioni rimangano
per tutta la vita di quell'individuo
a ripristinare la funzione
che prima non c'era.
Non solo, ma in alcuni casi,
come nel caso delle cellule
che vi ho fatto vedere,
sono le cellule stesse che diventano
il veicolo della terapia.
Quindi i farmaci diventano
farmaci intelligenti,
capaci di muoversi nell'organismo.
Stiamo imparando a sfruttare
dei processi straordinari della biologia,
le cellule che sanno dove andare,
le cellule che cercano
il sito della malattia,
perché hanno la loro capacità e portano,
attraverso la terapia genica,
la terapia in situ.
Questo può aprire un nuovo campo,
ad esempio usando le funzioni immunitarie,
uccidere una cellula tumorale,
ma in modo selettivo,
risparmiando il tessuto.
Si apre quindi un campo straordinario,
che può portare una risposta terapeutica
a molte malattie che oggi sono orfane
di un trattamento.
Si apre anche una sfida alla ricerca,
una sfida alla medicina,
perché qui parliamo di farmaci
più che intelligenti, quasi vivi.
Se vivo può essere un virus addomesticato
che finisce la sua vita
una volta che entra nella cellula.
Dobbiamo imparare a manipolarli,
quindi ci va prudenza, ovviamente.
Ci va anche competenza.
La competenza intorno al letto
di un malato che riceverà queste terapie,
richiede diverse expertise,
quelle del ricercatore, quelle del medico
e soprattutto anche a livello societario.
Queste nuove terapie saranno una sfida,
diventano terapie personalizzate,
le cellule del paziente diventano
il veicolo della terapia.
Ma devo imparare a manipolarle
e poi ri-somministrarle.
Anche questo comporta costi, impegni,
ma di fronte alla prospettiva
di offrire delle terapie,
che fino a oggi non erano disponibili.
Dobbiamo però anche
considerare gli aspetti etici
che ci pongono di fronte
a queste prospettive.
Siamo veramente nel dominio della tecnica,
ma quella tecnica che talvolta
si pone come unico dio
a cui la nostra società
sembra oggi servire.
E se volete ci sono anche
aspetti inquietanti.
Il DNA che vi dicevo prima,
quel manuale di istruzioni che è diventato
autocosciente nella nostra specie
e che può editare se stesso,
può andare a modificare
le sue informazioni.
Anche questo naturalmente
è un ambito difficile,
in cui è importante sapersi
muovere con attenzione.
Vorrei quindi concludere ritornando
a quelle radici della nostra cultura,
rifacendomi al mondo greco
e a quell'iscrizione sul tempio di Apollo,
a Delfi, che diceva "Conosci te stesso,
conosci i tuoi limiti",
invitando noi scienziati
e tutta la società
a riflettere profondamente
sull'insegnamento di questa verità.
La conoscenza che abbiamo della realtà,
e tutto il criticismo ce l'ha insegnato,
è una conoscenza di relazioni,
non è profonda,
non ci dà la chiave della verità,
ci dà soltanto la possibilità
di intervenire, predire in qualche modo,
e quindi forse, come scienziati
e come ricercatori,
la nostra guida, quella che può dare
ragione al nostro agire più di ogni altro,
è quella di essere ispirati
dallo scopo traslazionale,
dal portare un beneficio terapeutico,
e quindi ricondurre la nostra azione
in un orizzonte che può essere
quello dell'utile o del beneficio,
o anche, se volete, quello religioso.
Grazie
(Applausi)